-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
The Pentagon this week described
the unidentified object
shot down over Canada
on Saturday
as a, "small, metallic balloon."
So, it was either a dire
national security threat
or a wasted 25 cents
at a county fair.
[ Laughter ]
"Hold on to that, Tyler --
Oh, son of a gun."
[ Light laughter ]
President Biden is reportedly
considering making
a national televised address
to discuss the recent
unidentified flying objects.
Oh, yeah,
definitely please do that.
Interrupt
an episode of "The Voice"
and walk 30 yards down that
long red carpet to a podium
like Obama did
when we got bin Laden,
and tell the American people
you popped some balloons.
[ Laughter ]
"My fellow Americans,
it's true what they say.
Once you pop,
you just can't stop."
[ Light laughter ]
President Biden
announced yesterday
that Air India will purchase
more than 200 planes from Boeing
while Frontier is buying
200 planes from Goodwill.
[ Laughter ]
During the White House
press briefing yesterday,
a reporter from Newsmax
asked Press Secretary
Karine Jean-Pierre,
"is President Biden woke?"
And she rolled her eyes so hard,
they didn't come back.
[ Laughter ]
More haunting
than I think we planned.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said yesterday
that the back and forth
with Republicans
in his State of the Union
address
made him feel like he was,
"Back on the playground."
"So jealous," said Matt Gaetz.
[ Laughter ]
Senator Ted Cruz
told reporters yesterday
that he plans to run
for a third term.
Cruz said he discussed it with
his family, and they insisted.
[ Laughter ]
The company Volt Candy
has issued a recall
for its PrimeZEN Black 6000
male enhancement pill,
because it contains
two unapproved drugs.
Yeah, something tells me
the people who bought that
don't keep their receipts.
[ Light laughter ]
I think they're going to have to
eat the $9.95.
And it doesn't matter
how I know how much it costs.
[ Laughter ]
Two for $18.
The fast-food chain Chipotle
has announced plans
to open a new brand called
Farmesa Fresh Eatery,
which will focus on
farm-to-table cuisine
as opposed to their usual
table to restroom.
[ Laughter ]
A Philadelphia Eagles fan was
arrested on Sunday in Florida
after he allegedly
broke into a firehouse,
peed on the carpet, stole a hat,
and threw a knife
at a firefighter.
And then...
he found out the Eagles lost.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
a Florida city councilman
was arrested over the weekend
after authorities
allegedly found
10 grams of cocaine in his shoe.
Police first became suspicious
when someone in Florida
was wearing shoes.
And that was the monologue,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are off and running.